[Musique]
voilà le terrain de jeu de la première
édition du raid colossal une initiative
des enseignants de l'est pour le bonheur
des enfants et pour cela ils sont
arrivés très tôt ce mercredi matin à
fond quand c'est sûr sont faciles métier
[Musique]
l'intérêt c'est de temporiser avec une
épreuve où ils seront tous importés et
les obliger à réfléchir pour se déplacer
[Musique]
[Rires]
sur les 77 collège de lille 41 sont
attendus et 21 lycées et pour l'est de
l'île cette initiative a du sens et
l'octroi pour avoir adapté à notre
public parce que déjà c'est que les
vélos des profs qu'on a au chrono à 6 5
km et reviennent ici voilà au niveau
social c'est quand même difficile les
élèves vont pas forcément des vélos tous
les vélos là si vous demandez aux
professeurs je pense que c'est les
professeurs qui ont amené leur propre
vélo donc le département il donne une
subvention à chaque collège là je parle
pour les collèges de 800 euros pour les
collèges qui sont isolées comme salazie
sainte-rose 1200 euros et moins au
niveau du district en fait on a décidé
de mutualiser tout le monde donne les
800 euros et du coup moi je commande les
bus pour tout le monde et c'est ça
permet vraiment d'organiser les
compétitions d'organiser les
manifestations de pouvoir vivre dans le
district sens un autre aurait pas
commander les bus qui sont
plus en plus cher et ça va être marrant
ça va être sympa cette journée et je
pense qu'ils vont s'en rappeler retour
attendu x dès le début c'est parfois une
première pour certains élèves aient le
courage et la détermination prennent le
dessus des valeurs développées dans les
sections compétition ap hm les plantes
le de l'autre côté faut que tu le
pentagone avec aura lieu au niveau
sportif ça on découvre des activités de
trail de course d'orientation de vtt de
bike and run donc enchaînement de
vélo pour trois volets pour 4 puis peut
y avoir des épreuves de tir comme tir à
l'arc ou à la sarbacane sait il n'ya pas
beaucoup de sport où on est à plusieurs
où on s'entraîne mais c'est un défi donc
franchement ce sport ou les biens pour
ça et aussi c'est dans un bel
environnement c'est dans la nature
quand un professeur de places en temps
ça fait plaisir ça génial générale valeo
rozic on a en fait on a un petit peu
réussi voilà ils sont hyper souriant
hyper content d'être là finalement c'est
même eux qui nous pousse parfois
tunisiens ont fait pas plus
d'entraînements messieurs aujourd'hui
[Musique]
opération réussie pour un développement
des activités physiques de pleine nature
là où la nature est la plus verte
[Musique]